(upbeat music)
- How do you know when you've made it?
Well, here's one of our guests
describing the moment
they thought they knew.
- The moment I knew I made it was when
my mom was in town from Chicago.
She was visiting, I was going
through this audition process
for a show called "New Girl"
and about 15 auditions in,
I book it and I'm driving home.
And then my mom just called
me and we're on the phone,
having a conversation, and
she's elated and I'm elated.
And I don't know, it was just
one of those surreal moments,
like I couldn't believe I
was having the conversation
with my mother that finally,
I had done the thing
that I had set out to do
- Well, that was heartwarming
and adorable, I love it.
(upbeat music)